Brian, are you an Avenger?
I'm not an Avenger.
Nina?
Legally you're not allowed to ask me that.
Does Hawkeye suck? That's the question we've got
on the docket today. I'm here with Tom and Nina.
They are going to argue their positions. I'm going
to be the judge of whether or not Hawkeye in fact
sucks. On the pro Hawkeye sucks side we have Nina
Starner. On the con Hawkeye does not suck side
we've got Tom Meisfjord. So we're going to
do a little high school debate style thing that I
vaguely remember from when I was in high school,
about 10,000 years ago. We're going to start with
opening statements from Nina and then Tom,
and then each person is going to have the
opportunity to offer a rebuttal. And then
I will weigh in and decide whether or not
Hawkeye sucks. Nina does Hawkeye suck?
Yeah. Extremely hard actually.
There you go. That's my argument.
Good night. Yeah, that's it. That's all I've
got. Hawkeye sucks. So here's why Hawkeye sucks.
Here's why I have never given a flying fart
about Hawkeye. So he shows up in Avengers and
immediately gets possessed by the Tesseract. So
you have no idea who he is for most of the movie.
You're just like, oh, so he's bad maybe because
he's obviously fighting against the Avengers.
And then they unpossess him or whatever,
and he's friends with Natasha ... And
for the remainder of the movies, he
does exactly one interesting thing,
which is be married to Linda
Cardellini. Congratulations to that man.
But other than that, he does absolutely nothing
of value. He has easily the worst weapon and like
his connection to Black Widow is
something that I'll keep touching on. But
I'm always annoyed that everyone has ...
Thor has a hammer and Ironman has a suit
and Cap has a shield and they're just like
give her a gun. In that famous Avengers shot
in the circle, she's just reloading a tiny
shotgun. And I'm like that sucks. She should
have a better weapon than that. But his
is just a bow and arrow. He should be-
Which is worse than a gun.
Which is worse than a gun because it's slower.
And arrows, I would imagine take a very long
time to make, so where are you getting all
of these? And if you run out, it's not like
you can be like, "Oh, I have another arrow
clip." I feel like you have a finite amount
of arrows. It's fine for Katniss Everdeen,
but it's not fine for an Avenger. She
lived in the woods, he's in New York city.
He continues to do absolutely nothing interesting
for several films to the point where I literally
can't remember which movies he's even in until
we get to Infinity War and End Game. And after
his family vanishes, the beginning of End Game,
he gets the world's stupidest haircut and goes
on a vaguely problematic mission to hunt people
in Asia, for reasons I don't fully understand.
And then when he goes-
For sport, Nina.
You wait your turn, Tom.
Anyway, yeah, I will wrap this up in one second.
And the only reason that he gets to live instead
of a much more interesting character who I will
probably argue again gets shafted by the entire
cinematic universe by getting killed off before
her stand-alone movie even shows up. The only
reason that he lives and she doesn't is because he
is worthy of being alive because he has a wife and
children and she doesn't have a family. So that
sucks extremely hard. He should have been like,
"No, I'm going to kill myself. My kids will be
fine." I mean no disrespect to his kids, but
him having a family does not make him
more worthy of life. So Hawkeye sucks.
All right. Thank you, Nina.
You're welcome.
Very good, Tom. Your opening statement on whether
or not Hawkeye sucks. Tom, does Hawkeye suck?
Brian consider Hawkeye for a moment. It's
true. He has no powers. It's true. He has
a costume so dumb that even the MCU won't try
to grunge it up. And yes, it's true that he's
probably the kind of guy who would give
Cabela's gift cards at Christmas but ...
Oh my God, that's so good.
Does he suck? Let's consider his accomplishments.
He is an expert marksman married to Linda
Cardellini as my associate brought up. He's an
adoring father and with Quicksilver and Black
Widow under his belt, he's killed two times as
many Avengers as the next leading super-villain.
These are not small things. Consider Nina's
argument that he has a stupid haircut. I put
it to you that he has an awesome haircut in End
Game. And he carries a sword with him to work and
he's in his forties. How does that not describe
the coolest guy you've ever met in your life?
And I put it to you, Brian and Nina, that a man
is more than just the sum of his parts. We have
to consider where this man came from, Hawkeye
in the comics. Do you know where he comes from?
Ohio.
Brian?
Yeah. He comes from the circus.
Waverly, Iowa.
Well, I wasn't far off with Ohio.
The small town of Waverley,
Iowa. The Hawkeye State a little on the nose.
Yes, I'll give you that. But Waverley, Iowa.
I hate that.
Town motto, "When you're here, you're
289.9 miles from Chicago." Waverley, Iowa,
the home of character actor, Michael Talbot from
Miami vice. And that's it. Iowa the state, home
to captain Kirk, the itchiest Star Trek captain,
Miss Piggy, and according to Wikipedia, others.
And what did he manage to do? He picked himself
up by his bootstraps and he got out there.
He made something of himself. He became
an Avenger. Brian, are you an Avenger?
I'm not an Avenger.
Nina?
Legally you're not allowed to ask me that.
That's the end of Tom's
statement. Nina, a rebuttal?
Rebuttal. Yeah. If a guy I knew in his forties
carried a sword to work, I'd call the cops.
Because I'd be like, he definitely has
a manifesto somewhere on his computer
about people who have wronged him. And
I don't feel good about the situation.
Yeah. Okay, yeah. He's killed two Avengers. I
don't even know what to say. I genuinely don't
even know where to begin. Yeah. Knowing nothing
about his comics origin, even if I knew what his
comics origin was, I would still be like, oh, like
you could replace most of Jeremy Renner in these
movies with a cardboard cut out of Hawkeye giving
a thumbs up and I would not notice honestly.
His first appearance, he was in a circus sideshow.
Oh boy. Doing what? He's a regular
man. Did he just shoot things?
He's shooting arrows really good.
He's great at shooting arrows.
And then Iron Man shows up and he's like, "Oh
shucks, everyone's really interested in that
Iron Man. I better dress up in purple and then
commit crimes to show I'm better than Iron Man."
What is Iron Man doing at a circus in Iowa?
I don't think he was in Iowa. I think the circus-
He's - the magic of life's beautiful tapestry
I think the circus was in
New York at the time. I'll
give Iron Man that. No, he
wasn't at a circus in Iowa-
I was like that doesn't track at all for Tony
Stark's whole deal. But if you're a more casual
Marvel fan, like I am without the lore of the
comics behind you, you don't know any of that. You
just look at Jeremy Renner and you think about his
album and his app. And you're just like ... no.
Are you saying that you would have been more on
board if we included the circus situation in his
onscreen portrayal? Just 40
minutes blasting circus music.
Maybe that's what we'll see in the film.
Oh, no. I just thought of that too. I
was like, what if that's in Hawkeye?
I will leave the earth. I will not continue. Yeah.
Okay. Is that the end of your rebuttal?
My rebuttal is just nothing you said convinced
me. I still hate him. And I'm so mad that
Florence Pugh is going to be wasted on the Hawkeye
series trying to kill him because also that fight
should not be a fight. She should immediately
be able to murder a guy with a bow and arrow.
She is explosion proof.
That's right. We did find that out.
Yeah. And she killed a guy by putting
him in a bear costume and setting him
on fire and a different movie.
So she's capable of anything.
That's what happened to Ursa Major in the MCU.
That's right.
Told you.
Tom, rebuttal to Nina. I feel like you did that
kind of in your opening statement where you
took her to task about the haircut.
It's still stupid.
No, I don't mind to talk some more. There's
plenty of other stuff that we can talk about
with Hawkeye. He's a phenomenal character with
plenty of depth and nigh on 60 years of backstory
to consider, Nina Starner. He's a remarkable
guy who's been brought up in multiple different
iterations. We don't just have to talk about
the MCU version of Hawkeye. We can talk about
the Ultimate Comics version of Hawkeye written
by Mark Millar, the one with an Eminem haircut
and the sick hoop earrings and the gross
story where he pulls out his own fingernails-
He shot his fingernails.
And he throws them at people to kill them.
That's how cool he is.
We can talk about Lego Hawkeye. Who's-
I'm actually more, he has one hoop earring or two?
I'm way more stuck on the hoop earring
than I am the fingernail thing.
Two hoop earrings and some wrap around sunglasses.
Oh boy.
And he kills everybody in his
house with silverware from his
silverware drawer. He's a remarkable character.
We could talk about the version from the Matt
Fraction comic that won multiple Eisner awards
and told everybody that, wow, this guy actually
has something to do and introduced Lucky, the
pizza dog. That's a heck of a guy too. But I
think that my favorite thing about Hawkeye and
I had a lot of time to think about it is that
we were going to do this episode three weeks
ago, and then we had to keep putting it off.
My favorite thing about Hawkeye
is that if Hawkeye was ever like,
"Hey, do you guys want to talk about Hawkeye?"
He wouldn't make somebody wait three weeks to do
it. And maybe give them the opportunity
to put together an entire visual aid.
Has that been on your wall for a month?
That just sat.
Oh, no.
Like the eye of Sauron staring
down a person's anxieties-
So wouldn't you say, Tom, that knowing more
about Hawkeye has recently made your life worse?
Nina wins.
Yeah, I think we've determined.
Yeah.
Sorry, Jeremy. I tried.
Sorry, Jeremy. Knowing about Hawkeye
made Tom's life worse. Hawkeye sucks.
Hawkeye sucks. I'm sorry.
Damn it.
It was close. I wasn't sure
which way it was going to go.
Yeah.
Nina crushed it at the end.
You got it. Hawkeye, you suck.
Hawkeye sucks. Yeah.
You earned it.
Thank you.
Thanks for watching. Please
hit like and subscribe.